mortal engines to be a franchise
starting epic but it looks like the
grandest thing about it is the scale of
its failure
here's how this hundred million dollar
book adaptation turned into one of the
biggest box-office bombs of 2018
mortal engines is based on the 2001 book
of the same name by Philip Reeve which
launched a seven book series of sequels
and prequels the post-apocalyptic story
is based around the premise of cities
that are constantly in motion roaming
the world in competition with each other
over resources the protagonist is a
woman named Hester who wears a mask to
hide scars she received from a man named
Thaddeus an evil historian in London who
killed her mother to help her get
vengeance on Thaddeus Hester joins up
with a team of rebels who are fighting
to make cities stop preying on each
other and go back to sitting still and
that's honestly only the half of it as
you might imagine there's a lot going on
here just give it to me one more time
simpler over the course of its debut
weekend mortal Injuns made only 7.5
million dollars at the domestic box
office a crushingly low number that saw
the movie opening in 5th place the film
fared better in foreign markets where it
brought in nearly 35 million dollars
with the combined total making for an
opening weekend take of just over 42
million dollars relative to the movie's
budget that's an especially dismal
performance the production budget for
mortal engines has been reported as
being over 100 million dollars with the
marketing budget reportedly being 120
million dollars according to Deadline
that means it may have cost in the realm
of 220 million dollars to make and
market mortal engines with such a lousy
opening weekend the movie is pretty much
doomed according to Deadline than other
outlets it may well end up losing over
150 million dollars by the time it's run
is through mortal engines had the
misfortune of debuting during a crowded
time of year on its debut weekend it
faced off against Sony's spider-man into
the spider-verse
an animated superhero feature that
topped the domestic box office it also
faced surprising competition from Clint
Eastwood's the mule which came out to
one of the best financial performances
of the directors career and those are
just a brand new movies audiences also
spent the weekend with family films like
the Grinch or the record Ralph's sequel
still holding strong after
for weeks and theaters other big movies
audiences are still catching up on
include pre - Bohemian Rhapsody and the
fantastic beasts sequel with once upon a
Deadpool the re-edited pg-13 version of
Deadpool - also peeling away a few
million dollars worth of viewers for
itself oh you dropped a super duper
jumparoo skinny little toy PYP didn't
you buddy yes I did
basically there's no shortage of decent
movies to choose from in winter 2018
while mortal engines may have
distinguished itself from the rest of
the pack with it's weird premise it
totally failed to get people interested
in actually seeing it a movie doesn't
need great reviews to be a success at
the box office but mortal engines proved
to turn off to audiences and critics
both that must have been one lousy movie
after its opening weekend mortal engines
set at a mere 28 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes with 129 reviews being counted
towards the movie's average score
writers referred to the movie as being
wearying crummy and a giant slot with
even the more positive reviews typically
finding something to complain about
while some gave credit to the movies
special effects it seemed the movie
story failed to justify the spectacle
compare this reception to a movie like
spider-verse
which is a recognizable franchise movie
giving universal acclaim next offerings
like that mortal engines just looks like
too much for risk mortal engines biggest
problem may be that it's too difficult
to advertise the cities on wheels idea
is just too high concept and wasn't
explained in a compelling way by the
movies marketing this is less of a
problem for the book series which gets
time to build a world over many pages
but movies have to sell themselves with
intriguing posters killer trailers and
concepts that could fit in a single
sentence for a story that's this out
there that's a pretty tricky proposition
complicating things is the fact that the
book series mortal engines is based on
is relatively unpopular in the United
States compared to series like The
Hunger Games or Perry Potter so mortal
engines largely had to sell itself on
its merits as a movie it apparently made
for a hard sell imagining cities on
wheels in a book is one thing but when
you see them chasing each other across
the landscape at a movie trailer it's
easy to just be confused mortal engines
was produced in part by Peter Jackson
and
and Walsh with a screenplay by Jackson
Walsh and Philippa boyens they're a
creative team that rang in the new
millennium with their adaptations of
Lord of the Rings making a stone cold
classic trilogy of movies that remain
the gold standard for epic book
adaptations but whatever magic helped to
elevate those films - Oscar sweeping
greatness failed to come into being with
mortal engines with the property simply
failing to generate enough interest
among audiences one reason why the movie
failed is lousy timing when it comes to
cinematic trends Jackson originally
purchased the rights to the mortal
engine story over a decade ago when
adaptations of young adult novels were
more in fashion now the landscape is
much different and audiences apparently
aren't as attracted to these stories as
they used to be the darkest minds
another y-a adaptation released in
august 2018 also proved a flop on its
opening weekend but that movie had a
much smaller budget so its failure
caused less damage
mortal engines was a big bet that didn't
pay off whether the filmmakers thought
people would come out for the property
or for Peter Jackson they were wrong
nobody wanted to see it at all
it was supposed to be a franchise
starter but instead it's ended up a
fascinating failure
[Music]